[Música]
como avanzamos directo a donde Vamos
hasta Río de Janeiro con nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sacone porque allí
siguen las protestas de Los Seguidores
de Yair bolsonaro en contra de la
Victoria electoral de Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva Valeria cómo transcurrió el día
que allí es festivo en Brasil
seguidores
con el resultado de las elecciones han
protagonizado hoy en varias ciudades de
Brasil actos de protesta contra la
victoria de Luis Ignacio Luna da Silva
aquí en Río de Janeiro se han congregado
delante del Comando militar del ejército
en el centro de la ciudad a pesar de la
fuerte lluvia sabía millares de personas
ataviadas con la bandera de Brasil o con
los típicos colores verde y amarillo y
han pedido la intervención militar en
San Pablo sicabé el acto ha sido aún
mayor la prensa nacional hablaba de más
de 30.000 participantes y tachaba esos
actos de antidemocráticos hay que
recordar que muchos de esos seguidores
creen en las campañas de noticias falsas
por ejemplo que yahirl bolsonaro habría
ganado con el 65% de los votos algo que
es obviamente falso habrá que ver qué
pasa en los próximos días y esos actos
continúan lo que sí sabemos es que el
equipo de Lula está ya trabajando
directamente en la transición para que
el nuevo gobierno pueda comenzar el 1 de
enero
Valeria y entre tantos siguen todavía
las carreteras bloqueadas por Los
camioneros sin conformes con un futuro
gobierno de Lula pese al mensaje de
bolsonaro
los bloqueos siguen en al menos 15
estados con menos fuerzas y eso a pesar
de la acción de la policía que está
intentando dispersar a los Rebeldes por
las buenas o por las malas los efectos
de esos bloqueos ya se empiezan a notar
en supermercados y hospitales faltan
algunos alimentos y cada vez amáis
denuncias de personas que no pudieron
acudir al hospital para darse una sesión
de hemodiálisis de quimioterapia o
incluso para ser operados A última hora
de esta noche bolsonaro ha pedido
oficialmente Los camioneros que se
retiren para evitar que haya más daños
económicos y personales a las personas
pero no sabemos si ese pelo apaciguará
los ánimos lo que sí sabemos es que el
Ministerio Público ha pedido que se
investigue al director de la Policía
Federal de carreteras por supuesta
omisión en este en estas protestas
recordamos que es el mismo director que
no evitó que el domingo electoral se
controles a los autobuses que llevaban a
los electores a votar en contra de lo
que había dispuesto el Tribunal Superior
electoral que quería evitar controles
para agilizar el voto la polémica está
servida y las protestas siguen hay que
ver mañana cómo amanece Brasil